foreign
[Music]
and unresolved questions
these last years you have concentrated
your linguistic work on the discovery of
the conditions imposed on rules
that these hypotheses concerning
Universal grammar
this is the third Epoch of generative
grammar which I defined at the beginning
we may think of universal grammar as the
system of principles which characterizes
the class of possible grammars by
specifying how particular grammars are
organized
what are the components and their
relations
how the different rules of these
components are constructed how they
interact and so on
it is a sort of meta Theory
and a set of empirical hypotheses
bearing on the biologically determined
language faculty
the task of a child learning a language
is to choose from among the grammars
provided by the principles of universal
grammar that grammar which is compatible
with the limited and imperfect data
presented to him
that is to say once again that language
acquisition is not a step-by-step
process of generalization Association
and abstraction going from linguistic
data to the grammar and that the
subtlety of our understanding transcends
by far what is presented in experience
the expression mental organ has appeared
on occasion in these hypotheses
I think that is a correct and useful
analogy
for reasons we have already discussed
the problems concerning this mental
organ are very technical perhaps too
much so to enter into detail here
a particular grammar includes rewriting
rules transformational rules lexical
rules rules of semantic and phonological
interpretation
it seems that there are several
components in a grammar several classes
of rules each having specific properties
linked in a manner determined by the
principles of universal grammar
the theory of universal grammar has as
its goal to determine precisely the
nature of each of these components of
the grammar and their interaction
for reasons we have already discussed
having to do with the uniformity of
acquisition of a highly complex and
articulated structure on the basis of
limited data we can be sure that
Universal grammar once we have
understood it correctly imposes severe
restrictions on the variety of possible
rule systems but this means that the
permissible rules cannot express in
detail how they function
and it also means that the rules tend to
over generate
one cannot include within the rules
themselves the restrictions placed on
their application
what many linguists have tried to do is
to abstract from these rules some quite
general principles that govern their
application
the study of these abstract conditions
is a particularly interesting part of
universal grammar
I have been working on this topic since
the beginning of the 1960s
and more specifically in the past few
years from about 1970 I've been working
on and writing about some fairly radical
hypotheses on this subject
these hypotheses restrict very severely
the expressive power of transformational
rules
thereby limiting the class of possible
transformational grammars to compensate
for the fact that the rules thus
restricted tend to generate far too many
structures several quite general
principles have been proposed concerning
the manner in which transformational
rules must be applied to given
structures
these general principles are of a very
natural type in my opinion associated
with quite reasonable constraints on
information processing
in ways that are probably related quite
closely to the language faculty
but I hope to be able to show is that
these principles provide the basic
framework for mental computation
and that in interaction with rules of
limited variety and expressive power
they suffice to explain the Curious
arrangement of phenomena that we
discover when we study in detail how
sentences are formed used and understood
I doubt that they will work entirely but
I believe that they are on the right
track
this type of approach has proven very
productive much more so than I expected
in my opinion this is a reasonable way
to develop the extended standard Theory
some work has been published and more is
on the way
I feel that the work of the past few
years is much more encouraging than has
been the case for quite some time
I'm very happy about it
that is obvious in any case
yes I feel that we are getting somewhere
I hope that I'll be able to find the
time
however these recent results unlike what
was done previously in semantics for
example were not foreseen in the initial
program of lslt
these are new kinds of problems
considerably different
the theory presented in lslt permitted a
great number of rules
I tried it first to provide a system
Rich enough to express as much as I
could imagine
now in a sense I'm trying to do the
opposite to limit the expressive power
of the rules
in lslt there is no distinction between
rules and conditions on rules
that distinction appeared first in
current issues in linguistic Theory
with the a over a condition
the principle of recoverability of
deletion and a certain number of others
proposed as conditions belonging to
Universal grammar
Ross developed this approach in an
original and very important way in his
thesis
as did others
a recent book by Richard Kane on French
syntax is a particularly important
contribution in this direction
this line of research has proven very
productive
many misunderstandings have surrounded
your reference to Universal grammar some
have even taken it to be a universal
language
in my opinion this is due to the fact
that it is very difficult to imagine
what a condition imposed on a rule is
without knowing what linguistic
structure is
and without knowing what a rule is yes
for that a minimum knowledge of
linguistics is required
otherwise one imagines spontaneously
that is to say due to the philosophic
tradition internalized through the
mediation of the Contemporary vocabulary
that Universal grammar is like logic
that is why so often one has seen very
different kinds of people
confuse Universal Grammar with deep
structure
because by Deep structure they
understand the logical subject predicate
proposition supposed by philosophers as
underlying all language
this confusion is impossible in
generative grammar Universal grammar is
a sort of meta Theory deep structure as
we have seen is a technical term
pertaining to the particular grammar and
designating a precise stage in the
derivation of a sentence
in the same fashion some philosophers
have objected that human beings do not
have innate grammars as they think I
have proposed
this is simply to confuse Universal
Grammar with grammar
it is important to keep in mind that
Universal grammar is not a grammar but
rather a theory of grammars a kind of
meta Theory or schematism for grammar
in that sense
the theory presented in lslt or in any
general book on linguistic Theory is an
attempt to formulate the principles of
universal grammar
at least in the sense in which I am
using the expression Universal grammar
as linguistic work progresses we can
hope that it will lead to a deeper
understanding of universal grammar that
is linguistic Theory with the
constraints this Theory imposes on what
counts as a possible human language
as you have remarked much of the work of
the past few years has been concentrated
on universal grammar in a more clear-cut
and sharper fashion than before
the difference of course is quantitative
insofar as every formulation of
linguistic theory is intended as a
contribution to Universal grammar
but the remark is correct in that there
has been I believe some real progress
toward formulating the principles of
universal grammar
at least in the domain of syntax and
phonology
much less in semantics where research
has not yet produced principles of any
substantial scope or explanatory power
but as you emphasize correctly
Universal grammar in the sense in which
the term is used in the work on
generative grammar must not be confused
with deep structure
unresolved questions
today many linguists are working within
the framework of generative grammar
and on all kinds of languages
this theory has already permitted the
discovery and explanation of a large
number of facts in general the results
of this work are accessible to anyone
who wishes to take the trouble to read
them
however
in spite of the number of positive
results
I imagine that many questions are still
without an answer
certainly
but it is useful to distinguish two
types of questions
internal questions and external
questions
by internal questions I mean those that
arise from the moment when you begin to
work within a particular version of
linguistic Theory
for example
the extended standard Theory
by external questions
I mean those concerning the choice of
this General type of theory instead of
others based on quite different
assumptions
the epistemological status of the theory
the problem of the legitimacy of its
idealizations the interactions with
other systems and so on
as far as internal questions are
concerned they are innumerable they
arise whenever you attempt to test the
theory you have formulated and try to
improve it
there is no interesting hypothesis to my
knowledge which is not confronted by
counter examples that are very serious
for example the conditions on rules such
as the specified subject condition
in my opinion some of these hypotheses
are reasonably well substantiated
nevertheless
when you study complex linguistic
material a large number of phenomena do
not seem to obey these conditions
others seem to obey different conditions
and still others do not follow any
conditions that have been proposed
to be concrete take reflexivation
that is a process which varies from one
language to another
in English reflexivation Works rather
like bound anaphora that is the kind of
anaphora that one finds in sentences
like John lost his way where his must
obligatorily refer back to John
by contrast in John lost his book there
is no bound anaphora because here his
can refer to anyone including John
the idea of treating reflexivation as a
case of bound anaphora is due to Michael
helke who developed it in his PhD thesis
at MIT several years ago
it seems to me quite correct for English
and for a number of other languages
according to this view reflexives are a
special case of bound anaphora therefore
John hurts himself is analogous to John
lost his way and more generally the
conditions which hold for bound anaphora
apply also to reflexivation that is a
process which varies from one language
to another
however even in English this matter is
not at all clear
thus many speakers accept such sentences
as the pictures of themselves that I
gave them are hanging in the library
they thought that some pictures of
themselves would be on exhibit and so on
in his book
jakandoff gives many complicated
examples of varying degrees of
acceptability
a number have been suggested by others
too
these facts raise many problems
furthermore
in other languages reflexivation has
very different properties
this is true in Korean for example
while in English the antecedent of the
reflexive must be found in the same
sentence
in Korean the form that seems to
correspond most closely to the English
reflexive can refer to something not
mentioned in the sentence at all
this has been studied by watun Kim in a
recent MIT dissertation
the phenomenon is obscured by certain
rules which tend to choose an antecedent
nearer to the reflexive pronoun
but it seems that these are rules of
preference and in fact reflexives can
refer back to something given in common
knowledge or previous discourse
in such a language the rules of
reflexivation do not seem to belong to
the sentence grammar in the strict sense
the rule which governs the form that is
comparable to the English reflexive
seems rather to be a rule of discourse
or to be more exact
a rule which relates linguistic
competence to the other cognitive
systems that play a role in performance
there are also languages where the
behavior of what is considered to be the
reflexive is different from the case of
either English or Korean
for example
polish Japanese perhaps classical Greek
in these languages the reflexive must be
bound to Something in the same sentence
it appears but not under the restrictive
conditions governing English reflexive
rather some very general conditions on
anaphora involving domination
grammatical relation and perhaps linear
precedence apply
if you want to ask embarrassing
questions
you can ask me what all this means
does it mean that reflexivation can be
simply anything
certainly not
do these different classes of reflexives
have common properties
are they governed by other principles of
anaphora are they similar to reciprocal
pronouns how do they behave with respect
to the conditions on rules
in many cases they violate conditions on
rules which seem valid otherwise
is it that we do not know how to
formulate the rules governing the
reflexive
or is it that the conditions on rules
are wrong
or is there some other reason
all these remain open questions
for virtually everything that has been
studied seriously questions of this
nature arise
to answer them one might undertake
investigations of a wide range of
languages
I'm not sure that that is likely to be
the most productive approach
if the conditions in question are at a
certain level of abstraction
then no phenomenon will confirm or
refute them
only rules can do so
therefore one must begin by establishing
a system of rules to see if they are
compatible with the conditions
the phenomena in themselves tell us
nothing about the validity of a
condition on rules
they bear on the condition only
indirectly
to the extent to which the phenomena
contribute a system of rules that can be
evaluated with respect to its Conformity
to the postulated conditions
one cannot verify a condition by
referring to a traditional grammar
or by asking an informant
serious work on particular languages
shows how difficult it is to establish a
correct rule
only too often one's early assumptions
prove wrong
this does not mean that these abstract
conditions on rules cannot be falsified
it means that one must work quite
seriously on a language before it is
possible to argue that a condition is
falsified or verified
the problem is quite General
a particular language must be studied in
depth before facts and arguments emerge
which have real theoretical significance
you can always look at a language and
make some observations
here are the cases the relations Etc
that does not mean much
because when we study the problem
closely what seems true on the surface
may be quite misleading
these internal questions may not be easy
to resolve
they require hard work
one must study a language in
considerable depth to find the facts
that bear on principles of any
significance
serious questions arise concerning the
attitude one should take toward apparent
counter examples
at what point must they be taken
seriously
in the Natural Sciences apparent counter
evidence is often ignored
on the assumption that it will somehow
be taken care of later
that is quite a sane attitude
within reasonable limits of course not
to access
because we must recognize that our
comprehension of non-trivial phenomena
is always extremely Limited
that is true in physics and far more
true in linguistics
we understand only fragments of reality
and we can be sure that every
interesting and significant theory is at
best
only partially true
that is not a reason for abandoning
theories or abandoning rational research
at a given moment one has to cut short
the questions that arise
one must try to assess the relative
importance of the phenomena or rules
that contradict one's hypotheses as
compared with the evidence supporting
them
then one will either put aside
counter-evidence to be dealt with later
or else decide that the theory is
inadequate and must be reconstructed the
choice isn't easy there is no algorithm
and as this kind of problem arises
constantly in the course of research it
is an intuitive judgment whether or not
one should persevere within a given
framework
because of the positive results and in
spite of the apparent counter examples
in general there has been considerable
progress in linguistics
if one considers the positive results
even if innumerable problems remain at
each stage
methodologists sometimes assert that a
counter-example serves to refute a
theory and shows that it must be
abandoned
such an injunction finds little support
in the practice of the advanced Sciences
as is well known virtually a truism in
the history of science the willingness
to put aside the counter examples to a
theory with some degree of explanatory
Force
a theory that provides a degree of
insight and to take them up again at a
higher level of understanding is quite
simply the path of rationality
in fact
it constitutes the precondition for
significant progress in any non-trivial
field of research
and the external questions
with respect to those
there are quite a few that one must keep
in mind
for example
there is the question of the autonomy of
syntax
which opposes formal grammar to full
grammar is this an appropriate
abstraction
is it correct to say that the concepts
of phonology and syntax are defined on
the basis of formal primitive Notions
and not semantic Primitives or is the
distinction a proper one in the first
place
we have seen that generative grammar
replies yes to this question
at least certain Tendencies within
generative grammar this answer seems to
me to be the correct one with certain
qualifications
but one must not forget that these are
important questions in the same way one
may question the legitimacy of the
idealization of language in the first
place
is it legitimate to say that grammar is
a mechanism which Associates phonetic
representation and logical form
does such a system really exist
is one saying something correct about
the human mind
when one postulates that there is a
mental organ
consisting of a system of rules relating
phonetic representation two logical form
through the mechanism of syntax
that assumption involves a commitment to
the legitimacy of a certain idealization
but of course we don't suppose that
there is a box inside the brain
what this idealization means
has often been misunderstood
one can maintain with Ross and lakov for
example but such a system does not exist
that grammatical rules must take into
account personal beliefs and attitudes
if they are right grammar constitutes an
illegitimate idealization
I don't feel that there is justification
for this position
but the question cannot be brushed aside
a priori
to demonstrate the legitimacy of an
abstraction it must be shown in the
first place that it leads to interesting
results
then one must indicate how it is
integrated within a more General schema
on this subject just about everything
remains to be done
how can a model of competence be
integrated within performance models
models of speaking and perception
to develop a model of performance a
model of competence must be presupposed
it is difficult to imagine a coherent
alternative
it remains to be shown how knowledge of
language is put to use
however if for the moment there are no
other plausible approaches that does not
mean they will never exist
finally the physical realization of all
these systems of competence and of
performance remains quite unknown we can
only speak in very abstract manner about
properties of the Mind
what are the physical mechanisms that
satisfy the abstract conditions that we
are now able to study
what corresponds physically to these
systems and properties about which we
make hypotheses
these are fundamental questions
very little is known about the physical
basis of these systems
can one consider as external the
questions posed by sociolinguistics
it is conceivable
I'm not sure what these questions are
one can imagine that the definition of a
language or a dialect could be one such
question
it seems doubtful that these are really
linguistic Notions
what is the Chinese language
why is Chinese called a language and the
romance language is different languages
the reasons are political not linguistic
on Purely linguistic grounds there would
be no reason to say that Cantonese and
Mandarin are dialects of one language
while Italian and French are different
languages
furthermore what makes French a single
language I suppose 50 years ago
neighboring Villages could be found
which spoke dialects of French
sufficiently different so that Mutual
intelligibility was limited
so what is a language
there is a standard joke that a language
is a dialect with an army and a Navy
these are not linguistic Concepts as for
other questions of sociolinguistics it
does not seem clear to me that they have
been posed in a way that permits serious
answers
for reasons that we have already
discussed
the linguistic concept is grammar
sociolinguistics is presumably concerned
not with grammars in the sense of our
discussion
but rather with concepts of a different
sort
among them perhaps language
if such a notion can become an object of
serious study
as I've already said it seems to me that
any such study should be based on the
idealization to systems in idealized
homogeneous communities
beyond that it is not very clear that
there are significant principles
governing the extent and character of
the variability of the system or systems
in the heads of speakers or members of a
language community
questions of language are basically
questions of power
the kind of exercise of power that
created the system of nation-states as
in Europe
plainly this is not the only system of
political organization
for example in the old Ottoman Empire
regions such as the Levant Incorporated
numerous local communities related to
each other in various ways and with a
good deal of linguistic variation as
well
nobody spoke the classical Arabic taught
in the schools but the so-called
dialects were considered inferior
the intervention of the western Imperial
Powers led to a system of states
leaving bitter and unresolved conflicts
and antagonisms a system in which each
individual must Define himself as
belonging to a nation or a nation-state
it is a system imposed from the outside
on a region ill-adapted to it
much the same is true in Africa where
the intrusion of the Imperial Powers has
imposed a framework of National
Organization
that does not correspond to the earlier
nature of these societies
consolidation of nation states as
earlier in Europe interacts in complex
ways with the spread of national
languages
there are no doubt important questions
here
but it doesn't seem obvious that
Linguistics has much to contribute to
the investigation of them
what you have just said allows me to
turn the accusation certain
sociolinguists have made against
generative grammar back against them
they called linguistics imperialistic
because it was preoccupied with
idealized systems and in particular with
standard systems the study of which has
been facilitated by prior researchers in
short what these critics want is that
one studies the language of the people
you have just indicated to what extent
that notion originated with Bourgeois
power and in particular with imperialism
I can't see that the charge makes any
sense
for reasons we've already discussed
that the perfect speaker of an idealized
system does not exist in the real world
in the speech of real speakers idealized
systems interact
each of us speaks a variety of these
systems
intermingling them in a complex fashion
because the experience of individuals is
different the mixture of systems is
different
but I do not believe that outside these
systems there exist a reality of dialect
or language
perhaps I am wrong
perhaps there are constraints on the
ways in which linguistic systems can or
cannot enter into interaction in a
single Community or a wider group
or the mind of a single person
perhaps we shall find that certain
combinations are possible and others
impossible
if principles emerge which govern the
interaction of these systems
then these will belong to a field called
sociolinguistics
perhaps one may also find a way to
relate these principles to principles of
sociology
no doubt in social interaction all sorts
of questions involve language
perhaps the study of these questions
will draw upon and in turn influence
linguistic studies in some significant
way
it is conceivable
I'm personally skeptical
the situation is very different as far
as the connection between language and
cognitive psychology is concerned
there are questions with a fairly clear
content
and one has at least some idea of how to
approach them
one can look forward to significant
progress I think
do you think that a new type of
formalization would enable us to see
language from a totally different
viewpoint
for the moment we can see the sentences
as sequences of concatenated elements
that is to say one placed after the
other
suppose that certain facts tend to prove
that this perspective which is expressed
in the rewriting rules is not the right
one and that we must consider sentences
as discontinuous sequences
that certain elements can be inserted
between other elements
concretely that would be the same as
saying that the rewriting rules take
over a certain number of tasks presently
assigned to transformations
permutations inversions at Junctions and
so on
formally
these are models of insertion
intrication
I personally began with something quite
close to that that is with a much richer
system of Base rules and no
transformations in the work on Hebrew
that we discussed
so naturally I don't regard this
proposal as incoherent or out of the
question
such systems are certainly plausible
one cannot be dogmatic in this matter
it is necessary to keep an open mind
there are also other possibilities
it might be argued that a grammar is a
bundle of perceptual strategies
relating sound to meaning
that's a perspective very different from
the one we've been discussing
it is conceivable that we will
ultimately discover that this is the
right approach although I think that we
have nothing to support such a belief
today
once again
in the domain of embarrassing questions
I can see one that relates to your
question about base grammar
there are languages where no argument
has been found to justify one or another
ordering of categories at the level of
deep structure
these are languages of relatively free
word order
the phenomenon is very interesting
although as yet inadequately described
there are languages where word order
seems really to be much Freer than in
those languages usually called languages
with a free word order like Latin or
Russian which one can describe with
rules like the scrambling rule
yes in Russian or Latin in spite of
everything word order is subjected to
precise rules and moreover this involves
nuances of semantic interpretation and
of presupposition
this question has been studied by Ken
Hale
who found such freedom of word order in
walbiri that he was obliged to attribute
to such languages grammars of A Sort
that had occasionally been proposed
where the order of the base is free
like the applicational grammar of sound
John
yes
this requires other kinds of rules
perhaps non-linguistic ones
but involving such Notions as new
information
Etc
the grammar itself would leave word
order fairly free
at least one can imagine this
then one can ask are there actually two
types of languages quite different
or is there a super system of which the
two types are species
these are crucial questions which are
far from being clearly understood
in effect if two types of languages are
possible this casts doubt on the idea of
a universal grammar
in conclusion
you think that Linguistics in spite of
all the problems that remain to be
resolved is the only positive element
within the whole range of human Sciences
except for a psychology of the future
however there is one domain of which you
have not spoken generative Poetics
which was created by Halle and Kaiser at
the end of the 1960s
this completely new discipline can be
considered a human science
it meets all of your requirements it has
defined its object and its principles
it has provided itself with a theory of
interaction between systems the relation
between literature and language
it has defined its concept of poetic
competence born of generative grammar it
is not so much Applied Linguistics a
structural Poetics was
in my view this is also a field which
has a rich future
all this work is very interesting
however I have contributed nothing to it
and do not feel qualified to discuss it
here
I have no competence at all
it is one of the innumerable subjects
about which I have nothing to say